okay it's now clear that Donald Trump
really wants his attorney general Jeff
Sessions to resign he again took to
Twitter to slam his own cabinet member
this would have been unheard of under
past presidents and it's only getting
some attention right now because
absurdity has been completely normalized
yesterday Donald Trump going back to
Twitter where he said why didn't a G
sessions replace acting FBI director
Andrew McCabe a Comey friend who was in
charge of Clinton investigation but got
big dollars $700,000 for his wife's
political run from Hillary Clinton and
her representatives draining the swamp
so what's he talking about the
implication from Trump here is acting
FBI director Andrew McCabe who replaced
James Comey is friendly with Comey and
is friendly with Hillary and is thus
biased and you might be saying wait a
second I thought the problem was with
Robert Muller
Robert Muller was the problem for Trump
right now well yeah it's Muller and it's
also mccabe and increasingly it's also
sessions because Trump is paranoid he's
truly paranoid and if you were this
paranoid there's a chance you might have
done something wrong the discussion of
recess appointments or a replacement for
Jeff Sessions have been happening that
might be why Donald Trump is putting
pressure now on Jeff sessions to resign
I've said I hope sessions doesn't resign
I hope he forces Trump to fire him if he
wants and out and we now have reports
that Trump has been discussing with
confidants and advisers over the last
few days how would I put in an attorney
general during the August recess that
the House and Senate will be on in order
to circumvent some kind of confirmation
hearings and Trump this is actually I
guess a sign that there's some common
sense in the White House Trump has been
warned I'd wait for sessions to resign I
wouldn't fire him because there will be
major political consequences yeah it
does seem like it would have to be a
recess appointment especially because
you have Chuck Grassley who's the
chairman of the Judiciary Committee and
a Republican in the Senate says that
were booked out for the rest of the year
now obviously I think he could find the
time but he just has a loyalty to Jeff
Sessions
because session served alongside him in
the Senate for 20 years absolutely and
when asked Wednesday about the
president's discussions of this recess
appointment the White House put out a
one-sentence denial from Donald Trump
quote more fake news from the Amazon
Washington Post they're not even trying
to sound remotely dignified at this
point and the the quat be the only
practical question I want to talk about
with you is can the Senate circumvent
Trump using the recess appointment or I
guess it would be prevent Trump from
using a recess appointment and it's true
that that they could using what's called
a pro forma session which is a way to
prevent a formal adjournment of the
Senate Senate Republicans or Democrats
would be able to do this unclear whether
that's going to happen and it was so
funny to me when I read Trump is
considering this I thought Trump's
clueless how does he even know about
recess appointments the answer appears
to be TV shows Trump apparently got the
idea of a recess appointment because
some of the TV shows that he watches
we're talking about it and then he
started asking around about it you'd
like to think that he'd have some
experts in his advisory panels right
yeah you know the question is though why
is this happening now because Jeff
Sessions recused himself from the Trump
Russia scandal back in March it just
seems as if some information is coming
out he could tell that robert muller is
going to find something on him and i'm
just going to come to a head he seems to
have gone bonkers like even more than
normal when it turned out that Robert
Mulder was starting to dig into the as
part of the Russia investigation more
generally look into Trump's business
dealings and that seems to have set
Trump off which is also interesting
because remember we never saw his tax
returns that area something related to
either money laundering or business
deals that seems to be what Trump is
really worried about you would think the
right would be totally against
everything that's going on because this
entire maneuver right trying to obstruct
investigations looking at a recess
appointment to replace Jeff Sessions
this is all the kind of executive branch
autocracy that the right claims to
oppose the strategic firings and hirings
meant to influence supposedly end of
independent investigations executive
orders which were bad under Obama now
the executive orders are apparently fine
and now looking at a recess appointment
so I'd love to hear from some of these
Constitution
conservatives the the ones that have not
been ideologically completely bamboozled
by Donald Trump send me your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
you can follow the show on twitter at
david pakman show today's episode made
possible by tag adapt the hosting
specialist taga deb offers a range of
flexible hosting packages including
dedicated VPS and cloud server options
they also do custom server solutions and
colocation services taga dab has a
really user-friendly interface and
excellent customer support team their
expert hosting specialists also are
their friendly support team and they
give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga dad's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously
with a growing number of people
interested in moving their businesses
and projects that the cloud taga dad is
offering you as a david packard show
viewer or listener a twenty british
pound free credits about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers signing up
to give you a chance to try their
services to take advantage of it go to
sign up tagged adapt calm /td PS for
more information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up taga Deb comm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS
twenty